はいどうもおかんと漫才やっている
渡るwithおかんであり
パブリックスピーカーのわたるちゃんです
今日は顔と名前だけでも覚えて帰って
くださいよろしくお願いします
せーの大好き
最初に
質問があります
あなたは自分のことが大好きですか
僕は自己肯定感が低くて人の悪口ばっかり
言っていて
友達もいなかったんですがおかんと漫才
することとなりおかんから大好きっていう
言葉を教わることでどんどんどんどん自分
のことが大好きになっていきました
まずどうして僕がおかんと
漫才コンビを組むようになったのかについ
て
幼少期の頃からお話しさせていただきます
僕が物心ついた時にはおかんはずっと
寝込んでいる状態でした
産後うつうつ病ですね
僕はどうしてこんなしんどそうにしてるん
だろうどうしてこんな寝てるんだろうって
思ってました
おかんは毎日
しんどい
しんどい」って言って
布団の中で寝ていました
僕は
幼稚園に行ってた時バスの送り迎えがあっ
たのですか親がバス停まで行かないといけ
なくて
うちのお母さんはずっと寝ていたので
幼稚園に行くことはできず
孤独な幼少期を過ごしました
でも僕は
しんどそうにしているおかんの横でおかん
が大好きだったので一人遊びを毎日してい
ました
僕には歳の離れた兄弟がいます
お兄ちゃん2人とお姉ちゃん一人です
兄弟はお笑い番組を見るのが好きだったの
で僕もその影響でお笑い番組を見ていまし
た
兄弟の笑顔を見るのがとても
幸せでした
おかんを笑顔にしたいそう思って僕の夢は
漫才師になることになりました
でも僕はある時から笑わなくなりました
兄ちゃんが変顔で僕の前にバーって現れて
僕を笑わせていきます僕は思わず笑ったの
ですが
はいわかっ
たーって言ってきます
やって
思う
ことあるごとに僕を笑わせに行きます僕は
もう必死になってこらえます
でも思わず笑ってしまってそして兄ちゃん
が入らなかった
また兄ちゃんの言い方がもう嫌な言い方
するんでどんどんどんどん笑わなくなって
いきました
で小学校に入学して
僕は幼稚園行ってなかったので
友達とコミュニケーションするのがとても
難しくて全然内気な性格になってきました
うまくいかなくて
友達がみんなで笑顔になっていても
笑顔になってるって思ってもここで笑っ
たらあかん笑ったら負けやって兄ちゃんの
笑ったら負けが頭に残像きます赤もらった
かーんって言って笑わないまま僕はずっと
過ごしていたので
友達は全然できませんでした
そして中学高校もみんなから嫌われない
ように過ごす学生時代でした
学生時代の写真を見ても笑ったら負けよ
貫いた無表情の顔してますあえて目線も
ちょっとずらしに行くっていうそれぐらい
ちょっと笑ったら負けんもう染み込まされ
ました
お母さんは僕の学生時代もずっと寝込んで
いる状態が続きましたでもそんな笑わない
学生時代を過ごしましたがお笑い番組を
見るのは好きでしたし同級生の笑顔を見る
のは好きでした
高校卒業して大学入学してから
漫才師になるために相方を探しました
勇気を振り絞って学生時代に同級生何人に
も声かけていきましたが全員に断られて
いきました
全然相方ができないと思って
兄弟であるお姉ちゃんの声かけましたが
断られました
相方がなかなか見つからなかったのでそう
や
吉本興業の養成所NSCに行って相方
見つけようと思いNSCの願書を書いて
面接会場に行きましたそして面接会場に
ついて
隣になった人は相方にしようと思い
面接会場で待ってました誰が座るかなと
思って待ってました誰か座った思ってバー
見たらうちのお母さんが座ってました
そしたらおかんが面接会場のはがきの通知
を持って当たると思わんかった当たると
思わんかったでも手をもうわざと震わせ
ながら言いました
僕は何枚かNSCの感謝持って帰ってきて
たんですが
おかんもこっそり願書を提出してまさか
面接が当たると思ってなかったみたいです
オトンはおかんが前向きになって
起き上がるようになったので
反対されるかなと思ってたんですが
喜んでくれて応援もしてくれるようになり
ましたそしておかんと漫才コンビを組む
ことになり
吉本初の親子漫才師となり日本で初めての
お母さんと息子の漫才漫才コンビとなる
渡り増加を結成することになりました
ここからおかんと
漫才することになるんですが他の同期の
芸人からはオカンと一緒にいる僕を変な目
でずっと見てきましたずっとおかんといる
のに何こいつオカンと来てんねんみたいな
みんな同級生で聞いてたりとか友達と組ん
でるよ
みたいなまさか芸人やと思ってないので
なんやこいつみたいな感じやったんです
けど僕は全員をライバルやと思ってたので
あまり関わらないようにしましたでみんな
が漫才やっている姿を見ても笑ったら負け
やったので絶対笑わずにいましたしどっち
がでも心の中で全て
あかんから声をしました
そしたらその顔を見ておかんがあることし
てきました
口でこちょこちょと言いながら僕のこと
[音楽]
僕はもういきなりされてきたんでこれの顔
してる時に
咲いてきたんでやめろやって怒りましたそ
したらおかんが
渡る
そんな怖い顔してあかん
お客さんを笑顔にする人の顔ちゃうやろ
もっと笑いなさいということ言われました
僕はライバルである
芸人が
漫才やってるところで笑顔になるなんて
考えられないと思っておかんにイライラし
ながら女が言ったことを無視しました
そんな中僕らも漫才することになりますお
かんは漫才する前に
急になんか知らしました
舞台それのところで一人でまた
口でこちょこちょと言いながら自分のこと
を
急にやり直します
渡る渡る見て
セルフセルフコトコトや
こうやったらなんか笑顔が止まらんように
なるあんたもやってみいいって言ってき
ました
なんで舞台前にそれやらなあかんねんと
思ってそんなんやる前におかんネタ飛ばす
なよって思ってイライラしながら無視し
ました
そしてお客さんの前で漫才することになり
舞台は飛び出して始まりましたでも僕は
緊張して思った通りの声が出てきません
そして頭が真っ白になりネタが飛びました
舞台それ見てるライバルの芸人たちが
喜んでいるような気がしました
言葉が何も出てこなくなり会場も
静まり返り
誰一人と笑っていませんでした
漫才を途中でやめて学園に戻りスーツの
ジャケットを投げ捨ててペットボトルを
蹴り飛ばしました
そんな僕を見ておかんだ言ってきました
渡るものに当たったらあかんそんな
イライラしたらあかんあんた
緊張したかもしれへんけど
おかんは緊張せえへんねんなんでかわかる
か
おかんは全ておかんやと思ってるねん
何を言ってるか意味が分かりませんでした
そしたらおかんがこう続けました
会場に来てるお客さんもおかん
センターマイクもおかん
舞台のおかん会場もかんもっと言うたら
あんたもおかんやで
そして
全てを自分だと思って大好きって言い
なさいそうすれば笑顔が増えていくから
お母さんそう言ってきました
僕は
黙れって思って
イライラしながら無視しました
それからもライバル芸人が笑いを取るたび
に
余計に毎日イライラしていきました
イライラした状態が続いていきついにネタ
も思い浮かばなくなりました
ネタが全然思い浮かばなくなり自分の才能
なさにイライラもしなくなってきて
夢だった漫才師になったけど
諦めに近い感情にもなってきました
全然似たネタも思い浮かばなくなったん
ですがお腹が空いたのでスーパーに行き
ました
その時におかんが言っていた言葉を
思い出しました
全てを自分だと思って大好きで言いなさい
そうすれば笑顔が増えていくからここから
ちゃんと大事だから言うんだよって
お母さんからメッセージでした
そしてスーパーの店内を見てみると
どんどんどんどんすべてを自分だと思い
なさいということは思い出しましたで
スーパーに行き
全てを自分どういうことやでも1回やって
みようと思いましたで
果物という自分
野菜という自分買い物の客という自分
買い物かごという自分買い物という自分の
中に入ってる大量のなんかよくわからへん
けどめっちゃ自分っていうの思いました
何これ何やこの世界は
めっちゃ自分だらけや自分しかいない人と
比べてばっかりだけど全てを自分だと思っ
た瞬間に人と比べるって事がなくなり全て
が一つになりました
お弁当という自分を買って
財布という自分からお金という自分を出し
てレジの店員さんという自分に渡して
買い物をし終わったのでスーパーという
自分スーパーという自分を自分に自分を
売買しながら自転車という自分にまたがり
家まで帰りましたいいという自分のとこに
つきました家という自分のとこについて
お腹が空いてたのに咲き方弁当ダメ
弁当という自分を一口一口味わいながら
食べていきましたそしたら自分という味が
こんなに美味しいんだと思って感謝の
気持ちが溢れてきましたそして部屋が
散らかっていたのも気になってきました
部屋の空間というのも自分部屋が散らかっ
てるかなんかなんか自分が悲しんでると
思って
綺麗にしてしまいましたその点めっちゃ
自分が喜びました
あれなんか
靴が靴が見られてる自分を備えてみました
そしたらめっちゃ笑ってくれました何よ
これなんやこれ面白いなってきたなんや
思って
太陽
もいつもやったらうわー今日もなんか
暑いなあと思ってたんですけど太陽も自分
には思った今日も自分が輝いてなりました
雨の日なんですよね
雨の日はなんか調子悪いなとか気分が
下がるなと思ってたもうこんなやって
うわーもう嫌やなあと思ってたんですけど
でも全部自分やと思いません全部自分どう
いうこと
だと思いました天からオリンピックに自分
の顔いや何やこれわたるちゃん活動的に
そして雨も降って傘という自分を指しまし
た
傘という自分を指してその
渡るちゃんという雨の一つも一つがババ
ンってぶつかり合ってます
渡るちゃんと渡るちゃんが抱きしめ合っ
てると思いますよこれって思ってそして
ゴミが落ちてましたいつもやったらあれ
スルーしてたんですか
いつもなったらおばあさんが電車に乗って
きても寝たふりをするんですかおばあさん
という姿をわたるちゃんだってね自然に
できるようになりましたそういう風に全て
を自分だというふうに実践していくと
気づいたらライバルでライバルである芸人
という姿をした自分を自然に
応援してる自分がいました自分は一人では
ない
孤独ではない
幼少期から友達がずっといなかった自分
でしたが周りにはたくさんの自分がいまし
たどんどんどんどん自分のことを認め
られるようになっていき自分のことが
大好きになっていきました
そして大好きって視点で物事を見れるよう
になり相手に対して物に対して出来事に
対して全てが大好きになっていきせーの
大好きって言葉を気づいた言ってる自分が
いましたそして全てを自分だと思って
大好き」って言っているとどんどん
どんどんネタも作れるようになっていき
全てがスムーズに行くようになってきまし
たでNSEに入って最初の漫才の大会で
準優勝になりNSC生の中で唯一賞を取る
ことができて新聞雑誌に取り上げられまし
た
ライバルと思っていた芸人との関係性も
良くなっていきました目立っていくにつれ
て悪口を言っていく同期のメンバーもい
ましたが悪口を言ってるのも自分だと思い
あのーなんか悪口言われたと思っても悪口
を言われてこんな気持ちになるんだ自分は
言わないとこもう悪口を言った自分という
姿をしたらあなたありがとうっていう気に
なりましたそんな中
どんどんどんどんテレビにも出させて
もらうようになっていきました
順調に進んでいたところでおかんが突然
病気になりました
子宮癌でした
当たり前に行ける存在だと思っていたお
かんずっといてくれると思っていたおかん
おかんが死ぬかもしれないおかんがいなく
なるかもしれないと頭が真っ白になりまし
た
おかんのガンをどうにかして直したいと
思いインターネットで検索して調べたり本
を読んでみたり
必死になって情報を調べました
調べていくとインターネットである記事を
見つけましたそれはがん細胞をやっつける
ナチュラルキラー細胞が
吉本新喜劇を見る前と後で
基準が変わったという活性化されていった
という記事でしたおかんを笑顔にするため
に
漫才師になりましたが全然わかんの笑顔を
作れていないような気をしましたそして
入院制度管理に対しておかんという姿をし
た自分に
癌という姿をした自分に対して全力でせー
の大好き」って言ったり
するってやったりして
必死にありました
おかんにあんた泣きながら何やってるん
やって言われて大笑いされました他に会い
に行くたびにおかんが笑顔になってもらう
ことは必死になってやり続けました
その結果おかんの闘病生活は
毎日笑顔でした
奇跡的にがんも治り今のところ他にも転移
もありません
本当に良かったと思いましたこのことを
忘れてはいけないと思い僕は全てを自分だ
と思って大好きって言いなさいそしたら
笑顔が増えていくからこの言葉を全国に
伝えていってます
後日談になるのですがおかんがなぜNSC
の面接会場に現れたのかっていうと
お姉ちゃんが教えてくれました僕が相方を
見つけるのを苦労しているのをお姉ちゃん
から聞いておかんはNSCの願書を書いて
面接の当日はわたるを笑顔にするために
必死になってメッセージ会場まで来てくれ
たようです
僕はおかんは笑顔にするために漫才師に
なることを目指しましたが逆におかんから
たくさん笑顔にしてもらいすべてが笑顔に
なる方法を教えてもらいました
笑顔になることでこんな効果があります
笑顔の研究者ロンガットマンによると
赤ちゃんは1日平均400回言われお笑い
大人は1日平均15回
のみだそうです笑う回数の方がで笑顔を
すること自体が気分を上向きにさせてくれ
ますし笑顔一つで
チョコバー2000個分の幸福感を味わい
そしてまた現金280万円受け取った幸福
感を感じ笑顔が多い人は寿命が長くなる
そうです
僕は笑顔の大切さをおかんから教わりまし
たずっと
友達がいなかったずっと笑顔になれなかっ
た僕だからこそ伝えたいことがあります
僕は全てを自分だと思って大好きって言っ
ていると日常に笑顔が増えていきます大好
きって言葉最後にいいってなるので
大好きーってなるのでもう自然に口角
上がり笑顔を笑顔になりますそして大好
きって気持ちを持つことによって全ての
ことを好意的に見ることができます全員
から
好かれることはできないですけど全員を
好きになることはできます
あなたは自分のことが大好きですか僕は
自分のことが大好きですあなたもすべての
人物を自分だと思って自分に喜んで
もらえるように接してみてください
大好きな自分の状態にしていくとどんな人
と出会ってもどんなものを使っていても
どんな出来事が起きたとしても全てを笑顔
にさせてくれますそれを忘れないためにも
全てを自分だと思って大好きって言ってみ
てください
それでは最後に
全てを自分だと思って皆さん一緒に制度
大福って言ってみましょうでもここで
恥ずかしいなって気持ちもあるかもしれ
ないそれも自分感情も自分これ言っていい
から声出してもいいから声出していいのか
なって声出していいのかな全部自分やから
今出てくる思い全部地味だから行きます
恥ずかしい自分ありがとうと思ってね行き
ますせーのって言ったら大好きでいきます
せーの大好き
ありがとうございました
[拍手]